sur ce stand du forum des associations
de saint cyr l'école on ne vient pas
s'inscrire on récupère son chèque
associatif le shaq associatif est un
dispositif qui a été mis en route par la
majorité
après 2014 qui consiste à aider les
familles saint cyrienne à proposer des
activités à leurs enfants donc ça
commence à partir de 3 ans et ça couvre
jusqu'à 17 ans avec un premier
palier de 3 ans à 11 ans et puis ensuite
11 ans 17 ans de 40 à 120 euros pour les
3 11 ans selon le coefficient familial
et 30 euros pour les 11 17 ans des
grilles qui vont évoluer suite à l'arrêt
des bons sport de la caisse d'assurance
familiale depuis son lancement
la municipalité a distribué un peu plus
de 48 mille chaque associatif une
trentaine de structures de la commune
ont accepté le dispositif
on a quand même un tiers de familles qui
viennent inscrire leur enfant est une
grâce à ces chèques leurs enfants
peuvent pratiquer on a énormément chaque
associatif
c'est top parce que ça permet à tout le
monde de participer à ces activités et
ça évite d'être une
ce soit trop élitiste ça permet vraiment
d'ouvrir un tout le service jeunesse
sports et vie associative met en place
des permanences pour la distribution des
chèques tous les jeudi 2 septembre de
15h à 19h30 puis aux horaires
d'ouverture de la structure jusqu'au 31
décembre 2019